[Music]
all I have for you is a word
ten it it'll open the right doors some
of the wrong wants to use it carefully
[Music]
to do what I do I need some idea of the
threat we face as I understand it we're
trying to prevent World War three I'm
not saying I'm again you know something
was like I do you have an interest in a
sudden Russian national mics bring me
really one enough
you can communicate with the future
time travel no in person a mitten poetry
you know shooting the bullet you know
catching it
but I've said too much my well trying
keeper
your duty transcends national interests
this is about survival
seems both
hold up find that I thought you were
gonna say nuts
this is where our will score
how would you like to die oh you chose
the wrong profession
[Music]
I know that from here
hasn't happened yet
there are people in the future who need
us
I need tenant
we need to save them here and now
this reversing the flow of time wasn't
us being here now it never happened
you want to crash a plane but not from
the air no such master well having a
plane that part is a little dramatic
[Music]